We saw this earlier, although I was trying not to call attention to it,
but what happened is when we add something to a queue that is not full,
I'm going to increment the counter.
Similarly, I'm going to increment the counter when we add something to a full queue
when we remove something from an empty queue
and when we remove something from a non-empty queue.
Let's see. We want to make a two element queue to match my drawing.
Now, let's run the random tester. Okay, here's what it tells us.
It did 33,000 in sum adds to a non-full queue, 16,000 in sum adds to a full queue,
33,000 removes from a non-full queue, and 16,000 in sum removes from an empty queue.
We can see is that at least thus far as got really crude coverage metric goes,
and of course, we could have got similar information using a branch coverage tool,
but it is a little easier and more general purpose,
we can get coverage of our queue, and now, let's try something different.
Let's imagine that instead of a state machine having just three states.
Let's say that we had a queue containing 100 elements.
The dynamics are going to be exactly the same, sometime leaving a lot of nodes in the middle.
Okay, so we're still going to start at the empty state.
We're still going to randomly walk around our finite state machine and the question is
"Are we going to get good behavioral coverage of our queue in this case?" So, let's take a look.